[Music]
encourage you all to listen to what Dr
Wallock has to say you're going to be
entertained he's funny as heck but more
importantly it's going to be life
transforming especially if you're sick
especially if you're dealing with some
kind of illness especially if a doctor
has told you that you're going to be on
your this medication for the rest of
your life and there's nothing you can do
about it when you hear Dr Wallock speak
you're going to say like I said when I
first heard him speak it's obvious so
would you please join me in welcoming a
good friend a colleague truly an
inspiration my nutritional mentor and
somebody who's just a great honor and
privilege to say that he is my friend Dr
Joel
[Applause]
Wallock okay thank you Ben thank you so
much for the kind introduction and thank
you each and every one of you for being
here on a Friday evening you could be
out partying appreciate you being here
and for those of you who don't know me
just very quickly the thing that makes
my view different is that I have a
degree in agriculture and in agriculture
we don't have health insurance for
animals and we need to maximize our
income uh from Raising animals and so we
had to learn how to maximize their
lifespan maximize their production of
meat and milk and eggs from the same
amount of feed uh we had to have perfect
pregnancies no early births where they
needed three months in in the incubator
we had to have no birth defects and the
animals who were born on the farm had to
reach either reproductive age uh or
Market weight without need for health
care we did that with vitamins and
minerals went on to veterinary school
became a veterinarian halfway through
veterinary school I graduated a school
so I was a graduate student began to
take pathology courses wrote the first
paper on a mass die off in America from
pollution I'm sure it happened many
times before but nobody recognized it
got it published and that kind of
redirected my whole life uh graduated
vener school taught pathology up at Iowa
State University for a year and then got
invited by Marlon Perkins from the old
Mutual Mahal Wild Kingdom show and I'd
worked for him through high school to go
to Africa and work on the White Rhino
conservation project and the Elephant
conservation project caught 200 white
rhinos shipped them back to the States
and if you go and you see a white rhino
in a wild animal park or Zoo it's
probably one of that I caught or maybe
even offsprings are the ones that I
caught after two years of working on
those projects a Perkins sent me a
letter said look I I've got a big Grant
from the National Institutes of Health
we need to study the causes of death in
zoo animals and the people who live in
close proximity to the zoo animals
because they have the same air the same
water the same food sources we want to
found out if pollution or nutrition have
something to do with their causes of
death came back worked on that project
for 10 years in the Shar version is I
did over 20,000 autopsies and 10 million
chemistries uh on 177,000 some change of
over 454 species of zoo animals and
3,000 humans and the bottom line of the
study was that every animal every human
being who dies of what we would call
Natural natural causes not trauma but
natural causes died of a nutritional
deficiency disease and not pollution now
the book that came out of that 12200
pages is in the Smiths soning Institute
as a National Treasure and I'm just a
young kid and I was really very proud of
that and they moved me around from Zoo
to zoo university university so I could
deal with more species of animals and
different people eating different things
from all over the place and again to
make a long story short in 1977 I was
working at Emer University in the York
EES primat Center in Atlanta Georgia and
discovered the first documented case of
a non human with cystic fibrosis I'm
sure people had seen it before but they
didn't recognize it but because my vast
experience when it came to autopsies I
recognized this imediately as cystic
fibrosis got it confirmed by the experts
and then when I told them it wasn't
genetically transmitted that I could
create as many baby monkeys as they
wanted with cystic fibrosis because it
was deficiency of a single mineral
selenium during pregnancy or shortly
after pregnancy and I could produce as
many monkeys I wanted they fired me they
said Wy must be Sniff and glue everybody
knows that cyy fibrosis is genetically
transmitted and and there's no way it
could be some something you could
prevent reverse and create and so to
make a long story short again went back
to school became a naturopathic
physician began treating humans in 1978
and I've been doing it ever since it's
36 years been treating humans with
nutrition and doing the the thing with
nutrition as we did in animals so what
you're going to get is a view from
agriculture veteranary medicine as a
comparative pathologist and as a primary
care physician so you're going to get
four different views of the same subject
so bear with me and hold your questions
until later now in the beginning
doctors thought that all diseases were
caused by evil spirits or little Gods
sitting on planets and if you burn
enough goats to the evil spirits they
would spare you of disease and if you
burn enough goats to the good spirits
they would protect you that lasted for
thousands and thousands of years I don't
know if any of you ever heard of the
paintings in the lasow caves in France
these paintings are dated to 28,000 to
32,000 years ago and people who are very
very religious and wait a minute wall
the Earth is only 5,000 years old now I
live in hotel rooms and I've read the
Old Testament the New Testament
literally dozens of times over 36 years
I've been on the road you can tell
there's no place in there that says the
Earth is only 5,000 years old so I don't
care if it's 5,000 years old 32,000
years old God made it and that's all it
makes me happy but in these paintings
and you have to appreciate that those
paintings lasted 28,000 to 32,000 years
how often do you have to paint your
house once every 5 years they knew
something about pigments uh very
interesting stuff and they were painted
by shamans and medicine men and Medicine
women and and they told Health stories
and disease stories and then formal
religions came along and formal
religions and science conflicted with
each other uh one of my favorite stories
of course is Galileo and he wasn't the
only one but he was one of the more
vocal ones and he wrote scientific
papers on the fact that the earth and
the other planet circled around the Sun
prior to that the churches all believe
that the sun rotated around the earth
and the Inquisition committee from the
from the Catholic church at the time
condemned Galileo to death for being
sacreligious and going against the
church's teachings and belief and
fortunately for him a cardinal there was
a cardinal when he was a young man uh
became Pope at the time and was able to
commute his death sentence from being
burned at the stake to house arrest for
the rest of his life and so that's kind
of how there was a conflict between
churches and science at that time
several thousand years ago Physicians
and philosophers believe that there was
a cure all there was we only had to look
for it there'd be one treatment that
would cure everything was called the
panis that's where the word Panacea came
from and if you could learn how to
transmute lead into gold you were smart
enough to figure out that one cure for
everything was called Alchemy Sorcerer
And even Disney came out with a movie
The Sorcerer after a while the doctors
just got into trying to turn lead into
gold for the gold not for the Panacea
now Louis pasture came along the 1800s
and he came up with a germ theory he was
a a microbiologist and he was a chemist
for the wine industry uh to prevent wine
from becoming vinegar he came up with
the idea of heating it to knock down the
population of yeast and bacteria to stop
the fermentation process the same way
with milk and was named pasteurization
after himself now again he came up with
a germ Theory and in The Germ theory he
said there are certain bacteria because
they had just had a microscope invented
by a Dutch eyeglasses maker Bon Luen
Hoke and he could actually see bacteria
and he could grow bacteria from people
who had pneumonia and menitis and many
other diseases and then he could take
those bacteria and inject it back into
other people and animals and get the
same disease and doctors fought him over
that tooth and nail that would fight him
over that and so he had to set up an
experiment right in the center of Paris
he got to two groups of 25 sheep each
group and he gave one group a
vaccination which he created against
Anthrax which is a disease killed people
and animals and the other group got a
dummy vaccination it was just a water
being injected instead of the
vaccination both groups he injected with
heavy doses of the of the bacteria that
caused Anthrax billus anthis and in the
group that was vaccinated only one out
of the 2 died and the group that was not
vaccinated all 25 died and the reporters
were there PE thousands of people were
watching this as it went along and so he
became very famous over the anthrax
thing he was also the guy even though he
didn't know the term viruses he was the
one to first come up with a postexposure
vaccine for rabies is a virus thing and
he figured out how to do that very very
smart guy took a long time for doctors
to agree that yes there were germs and
once they figured out whether there was
germs they said you know everything is
caused by germs even cancer and insanity
and so forth and a guy by the name of
kooch came along and said no no you have
to isolate the bug make sure that it's
the bug inject it back into susceptible
host caused a disease again isolated
again get the same bug then you know it
caused a disease guy's name was kooch K
C about the same time there was a priest
in Austria by the name of Gregor mendle
and he was a very smart guy and he had
taken many courses and what we would
call today calculus and he could predict
numbers and things and um because he was
very smart and a detail kind of guy the
Cardinal in the parish that he was the
priest in put him in in charge of
creating peas for priests to eat during
the winter time and he had hot houses
where they grow these peas during the
winter time and there were peas with red
flowers there were peas with white
flowers every once in a while there' be
one volunteer a dozen of them volunteer
on the path between the two different
hot houses and these are ones that
weren't planted they would just pop up
and they had pink flowers and he
reasoned that they were a mix or a
hybrid between the red flower and the
white flower pee plants and he could do
experiments with cross breeding and so
forth and he came up with hybrids he
came up with dominance and recessives
and so he's kind of the father of
genetics but he never related the
genetic concept to diseases just life
itself at the same time Charles Darwin
came along and Charles Darwin did not
know about Gregor mendle but Gregor
mendle did know about Darwin Darwin was
a son of very wealthy Englishman uh they
were landed they had 10,000 acre Estates
and his mother was very wealthy she was
from the Wedgewood Family the English
dish wearer company and very interesting
stuff and he collected bugs and feathers
and eggshells and he would shoot Birds
and and little animals and make
Collections and when he was 22 years old
he wrote a paper for the newspaper of
the Royal Society it was very
prestigious for anybody let alone a
22-year-old guy write the paper and he
wrote the paper on invertebrates little
pops would make sponges and reefs and he
was hired by the British Navy when he
was 22 years old to go around the Earth
in the HMS Beagle a British warship and
build artificial reefs and he was so
successful at this they hired him for
another 3 years so for a total of 5
years darom was going to places at
nobody else had ever been before and
building his reefs but he was also
collecting animals that nobody had seen
before and he recognized immediately
well not immediately he recognized in
five years when he wrote his book On the
Origin of Species that parents of the
babies were passing on information human
beings had babies who were human beings
dogs had babies who were dogs puppies uh
cattle had babies who were calves um oak
trees had babies that were oak trees and
he'd find these weird animals and he
would shoot them and bring them back and
taxer them because nobody would believe
there were such things as Penguins
living in the Antarctic and so forth so
this is what he did and his book was On
the Origin of Species and Darwin never
said that that man came from apes but he
said all things all living things
whether you're a tree or a tulip or oak
tree or a human being or a hummingbird
passed on information to the young well
to sell newspapers the reporter said
that he said that men came from apes and
that wasn't what he said he said all
things pass on information is all he
said now his cousin Francis gton whose
mother was Darwin's mother's sister also
from the Wedgewood Family Francis gton
was also from a very wealthy landed
family and um he was in university and
his roommate was a guy by the name of
Arthur Conan Doyle the author of
Sherlock Holmes and Francis gton was the
model that became Sherlock Holmes in the
book in the series Sherlock Holmes in
the day people were just learning about
fingerprints and part of the parlor
tricks they would do when you'd come to
a party were to give you a piece of
white paper put your fingers on some ink
and everybody would make several pages
with their fingerprints and they would
exchange fingerprints and he recognized
by looking at these very carefully with
a magnifying glass that fingerprints
were different from person to person and
Francis gton came up with the idea to
use fingerprints to track criminals very
smart guy and that's why he was the
model for Sherlock Holmes he also said
you know we can speed up human evolution
like we do in Animals by selective
breeding just like we do in animals
that's why they have livestock shows and
dog shows and hor shows they want to get
the very best phenotype or the very best
physical example of male horses and
female horses and when the fo is born
it's going to be perfect same with dogs
and and same with geese and chickens and
whatever you might be reading he said we
can do the same thing with human beings
and he was very benevolent and he went
out and he started a dating club and
he'd hand out invitations to people he
considered to be perfect examples of
perfect Humanity included IQ and
intelligence and speed and athletes and
strength and both the men and women had
to be 6' tall blond haired and blueeyed
which he called the master race now this
was in the 1800 begin to sound from
familiar he would give out invitations
and he would have these tall young blond
head and blue-eyed women meet with tall
blonde blue-eyed men at these Banquets
and just by socializing he figured some
of them would fall in love with another
one and they would get married and have
more babies like them well after the
first world war the League of Nations
broke up Germany Germany originally went
all the way from Russia all the way to
Spain it was the biggest nation in
Europe they broke them up into their
provinces became individual countries
Hungary Czechoslovakia Holland and so
forth Poland after the second world war
there was a nberg trials and the nberg
trials was to find out who were the most
horrible of the war criminals uh they
murdered 16 million people they
experimented on them did horrific stuff
and they certainly didn't try any German
generals for war crimes because they
were just good soldiers uh they didn't
put any bureaucrats on trial for war
crimes because they were just pushing
paper and never made any decisions or
shot or killed anybody or butchered
anybody experimented anybody and so most
of the people who were executed for war
Crim crimes were medical doctors the
example was Joseph mangle he was called
the angel of death because particularly
twins he would kill one and do
experiments in the other one based on
what he find in the other one he would
kill people with birth effects cleff
pallet belly button hernas people who
had Down syndrome cerebral paly older
people who were infirm they would just
kill them because they were useless they
were in his terms useless eaters uh they
just took the assets of Germany and
didn't do anything productive even if
you were Jewish who they wanted to
eliminate if you were physic able to
work they would put you to work until
you couldn't work anymore they wouldn't
feed you because that was a waste of
food so when when you worked yourself
almost to death they would gas you now
everybody knows people who are found
guilty of war crimes were hung and of
course most of the people who were hung
for war crimes were medical doctors at
the end of the war now there's some
medical doctors who did horrific crimes
and they weren't executed and that's
because they had all this data from the
murder and experimentation on 60 million
people and they would call in uh to
generals and say look I've got all this
information here from all the
experiments we've done over the last 5
years and I can give them to you in
exchange for pardon if you don't pardon
me I'll just burn them and you'll never
get all the information that we
collected and many of these Nazi doctors
were pardoned because they turned over
the information to US forces and they
were made professors in US medical
schools all this information is a book
that's out now not mine somebody else's
book is called Operation Paperclip
everybody knows about Warner Von Brown
the rocket scientists we took from the
Nazis but we also got the doctors also
all the pharmaceutical companies we have
now bear fizer Ro Eli Lily were Nazi
pharmaceutical companies which they made
their money to run the war we took them
over for reparations this is how we got
paid for the cost of the war was
pharmaceutical companies and they turned
them into publicly traded companies and
of course and originally the government
owned all the stock they sold it to the
general public and that's how the
government got paid for running the war
now our doctors weren't innocent our
doctors did the same thing here in
America they did experiments on people
one of the more famous ones not the only
one but one of the more famous ones was
a Tuskegee experiment on 400 black men
in America who had syphilis and they
said look we're going to give you this
new penicillin but they only gave him
injections of water cuz they wanted to
see if these guys would die from the
same terrible symptoms that white guys
died from published many scientific
papers on the subject in Canada they did
the same thing they had what they called
residence schools and they would go into
the Indian reservations in Canada and
actually kidnap the kids from there
saying look we're going to give them a
better education we're going to feed
them better they're struggling here on
the reservations and nobody wanted to
believe what was going on in there but
they were experimenting these kids they
give tuberculosis they tried different
drugs to see which one would save them
and which ones failed and this came out
this is March of this year because they
found 50,000 bodies of kids under the
age of 10 in Canada that have been
killed during this program 50,000 in
Canada were killed in the same type of
experiments were done in Germany when
did this all translate into us being the
sickest country in the
world 1901 it began it actually began in
3:00 in the afternoon Monday September
4th 1882 we'll get to that in a minute
but 1901 something very dramatic happen
a product was invented to be a Machinery
lubricant called Crisco see Proctor and
Gamble didn't invent Crisco they didn't
did not invent hydrogenated oils the
process of fat hardening was invented in
1901 by willham Norman another German
chemist working on a machine oil factory
trying to find a cheap replacement for
machine oil which is made from Su which
is beef fat and they couldn't get it
well he came up with using cotton seed
oil and our corn oil that had a copper
co-actor and then they bubble hydrogen
through it and boil it and all this kind
of stuff and they would get Crisco and
Proctor and Gamble recognized they can
make a lot more money selling it as food
than they did as a Machinery lubricant
but they couldn't go against the butter
and the cream and the lard that people
have been using for hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of years so how
did they do that they hired a guy by the
name of anel keys and anel keys had
gotten a degree in anthropology and a
medical degree from the University of
Minnesota and anel keys was one of the
founders of the American Heart
Association death from coronary heart
disease became was rare until
1925 after they started selling Chrisco
to everybody their anel keys they raised
$1.7 million which made the American
Heart Association one of the more
wealthy of the medical associations in
America and they went crazy changing
everybody's ideas about eating meat and
cholesterol and so forth because they
wanted to sell more Crisco which made
the American Heart Association richer
now at the same time all the experiments
were being done was they showed very
clearly that the people who had the
higher blood clut OLS were the ones who
lived longer had less heart disease and
had no Alzheimer disease the lower you
got your cholesterol the more heart
disease the more Alzheimer disease and
the younger you died so it boils down to
personal ambition bad science politics
and bias derailed nutrition policy over
the past half century and caused America
to be the sickest country because the
American Heart Association wanted the
money they would buy great ads like this
they made them almost Norman Rockwell
pictures made to help take the fat worry
out of good eating bam you're dead anel
Keys was so famous he actually got his
picture on the cover of Time Magazine
and this was in 1961 Dr anel Keys father
of the low saturated fat and high oil
diet and drove Chrisco as a replacement
for butter and lard he's the one who
killed America Time Magazine December
2008 the sorry state of American Health
you have to appreciate we spend more
money for healthc care than all the 204
Nations the world combined we spend more
money each year than 204 Nations we rank
9 second in healthfulness there's 91
other nations whose peoples are
healthier than us we rank 60th in
longevity there's 59 other nations whose
peoples live longer than us and God
forgive us we rank 41st in live birth
and first month survivability of our
babies in this article they say our
children will be the first generation
who do not live as long as their parents
because of Ansel Keys Harvard Medical
School says 52% of medical doctors in
America are on street drugs or
prescription drugs or alcohol during the
Working Day this came out
4614 some times i' go into the bathroom
in the middle of a long surgery to take
medication intervenous another doctor
says I was absolutely impaired using
narcotics while working as a doctor and
no one ever tripped on to it or noticed
ARP monthly bulletin American
Association retired people monthly
bulletin March 2012 the worst place to
be in America when you're sick is an
American Hospital and I took some of
these out of the article so you can see
what they're talking about it says the
number of American patients who die each
year from American Hospital errors is
equal to four jumbo jets crashing week
that's 1,500 people a week 3,000 every
two week 6,000 a month 72,000 a year how
many of you would fly commercial
airlines if you knew that they killed
72,000 passengers every year how many
would go to and frequent a particular
type of fast food franchise if he knew
they killed 72,000 of their patrons
every year of course there's a big
controversy right now the a hospital in
Arizona was trying to stay in budget and
so they s railed hundreds of patients uh
for a month so they wouldn't break the
budget before the end of their fiscal
year and these 40 of them died that's
nothing new this came out in 1999 there
was a big study by the Department of
Veterans Affairs they said there's
hundreds of thousands of minor mistakes
in the VA system every year in America
3,000 which are so severe that the
veteran has to stay there for the rest
of their life in the VA Hospital these
3,000 serious mistakes want you look at
the word that the Department of Veterans
Affairs used they said medical doctors
and VA hospitals kill 700 veterans each
year last year in Afghanistan the enemy
killed 375 Act military personnel you're
safer on a field of battle than you're
in a VA Hospital God forgive us
according to the Wall Street Journal
looking at December 2012 each surgeon in
America makes thousands of Errors each
year 52% are gorked out on drugs and
alcohol street drugs prescription drugs
and alcohol here's one of my favorite
examples this girl here young lady 28
years old went into a general hospital
in Orlando florid to have her first baby
the OBG who was intoxicated cut her arms
off at the elbows cut her legs off of
the groin he never had his license
suspended for 3 seconds he went out and
had martinis that afternoon she's never
gotten anything for it somebody needs to
go to jail here this is one of my
favorites because it shows you very
clearly where they got the information
this was the USA Today in February 2007
look at the title it's self-explanatory
patient protect thyself and the data
came from The Institute of medicine
which is kind of a ethical Watchdog for
the medical profession and then the
Journal of the American Medical
Association the most prestigious medical
journal in America certainly maybe the
world and then the Centers for Disease
Control which is the Watchdog for the
federal governments in Atlanta Georgia
and their combined data this is a yearly
figure said each year in America medical
doctors kill injur and infect 15 million
of their patients in their workplace
each year in America medical doctors
kill injur and infect 15 million of
their patients in their Hospitals and
Clinics how many would fly commercial
airlines if you knew they killed injured
infected 15 million passengers every
year nobody would fly yet you still go
to doctors I find that amazing how much
control the doctors have over you
everybody knows about Bernie maid off he
he went to jail for life for defrauding
his investors of $3 billion well this
came out in September of 2012 front page
article in many newspapers around
America now this is not government the
the title us Healthcare weighs $750
billion you you kind of get the sense
that there government making the waste
no when you read the article it says
your doctor your doctor not the
government your doctor of every dollar
that he bills you in your insurance
company 30 cents of it is a fraudulent
billing 30 cents of it is either for
procedures he's billing for that he did
didn't do but he needed the money for
his kids to go to Harvard and all that
kind of stuff for their tuition his wife
wanted a um Mercedes convertible and so
he just took your ID number for your
insurance company build them or he did
something for you that you really didn't
need and he build for that 30 cents out
of every dollar it amounts to $750
billion a year that's 34 of a trillion
dollars each year onethird of the
American Medical budget and not a single
doctor gets his license suspended for 3
seconds a single doctor has his license
revoked nobody goes to jail nobody gets
the equivalent fine as a parking ticket
Bernie mid off went to life for $3
billion doctors get a walk for 3/4 of a
trillion start breaking that down a
little bit the Center for Disease
Control again the federal agency in
Atlanta Georgia tracks his stuff just in
hospitals alone each year not private
offices and Clinics just in hospitals
alone medical doctors infect 2 million
patients because they don't wash their
hands after they go potty and other
those 2 million infections 90,000 die
what would happen if Iran or North Korea
were to send over intercontinental
ballistic missiles with biological
weapons infect 2 million people in our
large population centers Miami Atlanta
New York New York New Jersey
Philadelphia places like Cincinnati Ohio
Chicago Dallas Texas LA and killed
990,000 this is a yearly figure this
isn't one time this goes on and on and
on year after year after year and nobody
seems to care but we'd go to war with
Iran we'd vaporize them with an atomic
weapon if they do that to one of our
cities but the medical doctors have
legislated themselves into being a
protected Monopoly self- policing
they've also legislated all of their
competition into being class citizens
quacks who cannot be paid by insurance
when you get a roof on your house or put
an irrigation system in your house
you're going to get three four five bids
or more after you choose what you think
is the best one based on what they're
telling you and the contract they
propose for you you're still going to
before you sign the contract you're
going to go to the Better Business
Bureau and see if there's any complaints
about these companies you're looking at
you go to the same doctor year after
year after year after year for 20 30
years whatever he says you do you don't
even question it you don't even go get a
second opinion and that's what's killing
America one bacteria diff CLA stream
diff is still a human poop bacteria
kills 30,000 each year in hospitals
alone that's onethird of those 990,000
are killed by infections are killed by
sea diff only found in human poop
doctors give it to people because they
don't wash your hands after they go
potty well in 1993 they
85,00 these infections in American
hospitals 17 years later 2010 it went up
400% to almost 350,000 from 85,000 and
so does this give you a sense that
doctors are really working hard to solve
the problem no there's no consequences
why it looks like that if you were to
take the top 50 doctors who kill a th
people a week and hang them and then
take the next thousand doctors who kill
25 week and put them in jail for Life
the table would look like that wouldn't
it because there's consequences the
reason why the table looks like this is
there's no
consequences the Chinese have figured
out how to deal with this there's two
types of Chinese doctors the traditional
Chinese medical doctors are called the
Barefoot doctors um they go back a
thousand years before Egyptian doctors
Egyptian doctors came online about 4,000
years ago the Chinese traditional
Chinese medical doctors came on a
thousand years before that acupuncture
herbs great writings and so forth um the
yellow Emperor recorded all this stuff I
mean this goes way way back thousands of
years and during the second world war
the Japanese soldiers were moving ahead
of their supply line they were starving
and they were poor and they would strip
like Locust they would strip the
civilian population of everything and
the doctors had the best shoes so they
always wanted to get the Doctor's shoes
so the traditional Chinese medical
doctors were called the Barefoot doctors
they would go go out to the Villages and
and help people with acupuncture and
herbs and they were be loved by by the
people of the villages well after the
second world war the Chinese sent their
very brightest young medical students to
the United States and Canada and Europe
for Western Medical Training and they
came back and began to kill the Chinese
patients just like Western Medical
Doctors do here in in North America and
Europe the Chinese have figured out how
to solve the problem each year grieving
families kill
27.3 doctors in each Hospital on the
average who killed a relatives and this
is considered justifiable homicide so
the government is now trying to say okay
come on guys let's cool our Jets let's
not do this anymore we know it's listed
as justifiable homicide that when you
know a doctor kills your father the
brothers and the sons Go and Kill the
doctor with axes and Hammers and all
those kind because they're not allowed
to have guns so they have to do with
primitive weapons and I'm not proposing
that that we kill doctors but what I am
proposing is we take care of ourselves
enough where we don't need them if you
don't need them they'll pack up and
leave couple more and then we'll get
into the diseases deaths by medication
error Rising this came out in 2006 this
is a national story United States
medication errors these types of
mistakes are tied to 1.5 million
fatalities and permanent injuries each
year in America alone and everybody
wants to take medication I find that
amazing a federal jury in Lafayette
Louisiana lodged a punitive damage
against Eli Lily and their Japanese um
Partners for9 billion over hiding ose
risks now what is that ose of course is
a extremely well-respected drug that's
used for diabetes I mean it will lower
your blood sugar but everybody who takes
ose gets cancer they forgot to tell you
that part they conspired to keep that
piece secret and so a federal jury ding
them $9 billion I thought that was cool
yeah problem is that's chump change for
them that's like charging you a nickel
for a parking ticket none of the guys
who are in on the conspiracy lost their
jobs none of them got a fine a parking
ticket they got nothing the company got
ding 9 billion but again it's like you
being charged a nickel hospital care
fatal for some patients uh this study
was actually done by the US Department
of Health and Human Services office of
Inspector General which is essentially
the auditor for Medicare what they did
was look at the monthly kill rate by
medical doctors on seniors people who
were on Medicare this is a monthly
figure medical doctors kill 15,000
Medicare patients in hospitals with
minor medical procedures and screening
tests how many of were AG 65 would fly
commercial airlines if you knew that
they killed 15,000 seniors every month
that's 180,000 a year nobody would fly
over AG 65 but you still go to doctors
why because of insurance I'll show you
three people very famous people that
they killed last couple of years were
overage 65 Andy Rooney from 160 minutes
was 92 years old he his 87y old wife
were going to go on a world cruise for a
year and she was nervous at Andy I'm 87
you're '92 one of us is going to get
sick here and we need to take a disc
with our medical records in case because
we don't even speak the languages the
place we're going so he agrees they go
to the doctor and while the disc are
being burned on the records his doctor
is going through his paper and saying
you know Andy you're 92 years old I I
can't see where you've ever had a
colonoscopic exam you could have cancer
lurking around in you and he should have
said no I don't have any blood in my
stool I don't I'm not losing weight I
don't have any pelvic pain I haven't had
any change in my bowel habits and so I'm
not going to get a colonoscopic exam but
instead he said oh okay Andy Rooney the
skeptical guy was a compliant 90-year
old guy goes in the next day the doctor
sticks a garden hose up his rump
puncture his intestine 3 Days Later he's
dead from par eyes belly infection when
you look online Andy Rooney obituary no
matter what service you're looking at
they all say the same thing was a news
release okay from 60 minutes they said
Mr Rooney died from complications of a
minor medical procedure wasn't minor for
him it killed him and then Dick Clark
American Bandstand 8 years old goes in
for physical complains to his doctor he
gets up in the middle of the night to go
to the bathroom the doctor say you
probably having a large prostate sends
him urologist urologist exam say yeah
you got a large prostate dick we need to
um cut part of your prostate gland out
we're going to put you on prescriptions
and I could see Dick Clark kind of
arguing a little bit he said well I
don't think I need surgery well yes you
do listen dick this is a minor procedure
um you don't have to stay in the
hospital overnight it's an out page it's
like clipping your fingernails for
goodness sakes you come in at 9:00 9:30
you're done 1:00 you're on the golf
course for goodness sakes don't be a
wimp he should have said no but he said
okay goes in at 9:00 9:30 is dead the
doctor forgot to tell him was when you
cut on the prostate gland it releases a
hormone that causes your risk of
thrombotic stroke coronary trombosis
pulmonary emm to go up well he won the
lottery he got all three and died when
at 9:00 9:30 was dead but my favorite is
Neil Armstrong our top astronaut first
man to walk on the moon personally saved
two doomed NASA missions 8 years old
went in for his physical the doctors
came out saying that NASA program must
be wonderful Neil you're 82 years old
but you got the blood work and the
physical body of a 50y old guy the only
thing we can find is one coronary artery
way down at the tip has a 3mm wide 30%
blockage you're not going to have any
chest pain angina because it's too low
it had to be high up in the artery have
the pain there's really no risk of
having a heart attack cuz it's too low
it has to be high up in the in the
artery to have risk for heart attack but
it could be a progressive thing and if
you let us we'd recommend doing a a
putting in a stint r two and doing a
bypass r two you'll never have to worry
about a heart attack from these arteries
and he should have said no no no but
instead he said yes sir let's do it 3
days later he was dead what did he died
from complications of an elective
cardiovascular procedure elective means
he really didn't need it all the doctors
went out and had martinis say GE we
killed Neil Armstrong can you believe
that now if Al qaa would have kidnapped
him cut his head off in YouTube we sent
in drones to blow up baby food factories
in case had biological weapons in there
we'd certainly send in sealed Team Six
to kill a bunch of people but let a
doctor kill our top Astron it's okay now
to me this is the most important part of
life the first 91 days of pregnancy the
baby's going down an assembly line and
like a factory say making cars TVs
refrigerators tractors furnaces whatever
it's making there has to be stations
where they has all the parts and you got
a team of guys installing these parts
they're handing them to them the one guy
putting the parts in then it goes on to
the next station they put in the parts
and it goes to the next station if
somebody has to run to the bathroom
there's nobody there to kind of keep up
with it nobody stops the assembly line
that furnace or that car will get to the
line be pieces missing the same thing
happens with babies there's pieces
missing this is what causes birth
effects because the mother was missing
something well whose fault is that it's
the OBGYN the OBGYN is just is
responsible for every birth def you can
name there's a single birth defect is
caused genetically it's all caused by
nutritional deficiencies of the embryo
the last six mon months of pregnancy is
just growth by the time 91 days goes by
you've got what you got and then the
next six months are just growth anybody
here ever hear of things that are called
inbar errors and Metabolism anybody ever
hear inbar errors and Metabolism okay
inbar errors and Metabolism are things
that are missing during the formation of
the embryo in the early stages in the
first couple of weeks of the embryo's
life and the baby comes out with stuff
that doesn't happen properly for
instance how many of you heard of
lactose intolerance you drink milk eat
cheese eat ice cream you get bubbly
intestines and is painful and bloating
and diarrhea it's called lactose
intolerance because you're missing the
enzyme lactase because mama was missing
something that enzyme was being formed
you can make up the difference by
supplementing with lactase and you take
the enzyme and then go knock yourself
out e all the ice cream and cheese you
want and no problem same thing is true
with fructose intolerance um same thing
similar is true to PKU phenol ketal Uria
where we mama left out the piece that's
required to to properly break down an
amino acid called phenol alanine if you
don't properly break down pH alanine the
metabolic pieces that are left over that
aren't broken down will cause
retardation now what you have to do here
for this is to avoid it and so by law
any food product or anything you're
going to eat for put in your mouth that
has phenol analine they have to say
warning PKU patients this product
contains fetal alanine do not take it if
you're a p PKU patient so by avoidance
you can prevent the disease same thing
is true with type 1 diabetes is an
inborn a metabolism it's not a genetic
thing Mamu is missing something when the
cells that form insulin the beta cells
they were never farmed and so the baby
is going to be on insulin for the rest
of its life it's an inborn air
metabolism we have type 1 diabetes type
two diabetes is a simple mineral
deficiency it's easily reversed now in
black people they have a disease called
cocel anemia the same disease in white
people is called phemia this is where
the mother is having the baby go down
the assembly line and when the bone
marrow is being formed the part that
makes the hemoglobin there's something
missing and the hemoglobin has what's
called the CLE cell trait or the phemia
trait you're missing nutrients instead
of being like this normal red blood cell
over here looks like a little dut they
will sickle and look like grains of
wheat maybe even look like a sickle and
so they you can see where these would
clog up little arteries and cause
strokes and swelling and all kinds of
other complications and so by
supplementing with the 90 cent of
nutrients which we'll get into in a
minute and taking some extra selenium
and some extra B6 you can prevent people
who have that CLE cell trait from
sickling been doing this since 1991 in
people in Atlanta Georgia in the Georgia
CLE cell Foundation you all heard of
down syndrome Down syndrome is not
genetically transmitted Down syndrome is
actually caused by a zinc deficiency in
the first 10 minutes of pregnancy I've
actually reversed them uh not after the
baby's born not after 91 days but Lauren
Canal evil Canal's niece-in-law uh
called me about 12 years ago and she
said look doc I've got a pregnancy it's
two and a half months along uh by two
different tests from two different
Laboratories they tell me I have a baby
with Down Syndrome I don't want to have
an abortion and they tell me you might
be able to help me I said well we've
done it in animals never done in humans
and she said well I'm not going to get
an abortion so you know this is not
going to be a problem just let's do it
and so what I did was give her the 90
essential nutrients and give her some
extra zinc and the baby was born
perfectly normal later on done it
several times since okay early on in
pregnancy with a Down Syndrome baby
apparently they are reversible but once
the baby's 91 days you can't you've all
heard of spinabifida one of the lawsuits
I lodged against the FDA was over folic
acid uh supplementation and prenatal
vitamins until we sued them there was no
law requiring folic acid and prenatal
vitamins and babies would be barn with
spinabifida this baby also has a zinc
deficiency because he got club feet this
baby has a gluten intolerance because he
barned with no hair all this is
avoidable by Perfect nutrition and
corrective diets before conception whose
fault is this the OBGYN I told you I
discovered the first non-human case of
cystic fibrosis Reus monkey y's primate
Center in Atlanta Georgia emry
University and of course they fired me
for saying it wasn't genetic and about 5
years ago we began to send Jerry Lewis
papers and and Records of kids whose
musopia had been reversed we had learned
the cause prevention cure of musopia in
animals in 1957 and over the years I had
used it every once in a while I'd see a
mustardy kid and we were able to reverse
it and I'd see another one three or four
years later and we' be able to reverse
it it wasn't big enough numbers to to
make any impact on science about 5 years
ago one of our Associates Marvin Rob who
is a Navy SEAL but he started out as an
Amish kid when he reached 18 He shaved
his beard off gave his team of horses to
his brother joined the Navy and became a
Navy SEAL very highly decorated he came
back and he was just really really
offended because the medical doctors are
using the Amish as an ATM machine
telling them all their disease were
genetic and there's nothing to do about
it and they were just ripping these poor
people off so we gave Jerry Lewis all
the paperwork and so Jerry Lewis got
excited say Jerry we don't want any
money we've already spent the time and
money and effort we we now know what we
believe is the cause prevention cure of
musty do you want to be the one these
are Jerry's kids do you want to be the
one to make the announcements he got
excited he took all this data to the
medical Committee of mus fee foundation
and they fired Jerry Lewis four years
ago that's why he's not doing the
telmore they fired Jerry Lewis he's not
sick he's not dead he's doing shows in
Vegas every night they fired Jerry Lewis
somebody needs to go to jail well 1989
with malan I went to China and went to
kishan Province China why did I go there
because everybody knows the kishan
disease which occurs in 13 out of every
thousand kids there is a cardiopathy
heart disease so sudden heart death is
caused by deficiency of selenium we know
a deficiency of selenium is the cause of
cystic fibrosis and the cause of
muscular hisy and I I reason that if
this is true and everybody includ
including the World Health Organization
agreed that kesan disease is cardium the
heart disease is caused by a SL
deficiency there had to be some kids
there in China with cystic fibrosis musy
and experts when I asked him about they
said no come on wall um Cissy FiOS says
musy only occur in white kids from
Eastern European origin well I knew that
wasn't true because I had autopsy black
kids and Oriental kids Asian kids that
had these diseases C fibrosis musy so I
knew that couldn't be true so we went
there passed all the tests did
everything we needed to do to satisfy
the Chinese government that we knew we
were doing they were going to get their
credit for and did 1,700 autopsies in
kids under the age of 10 595 of them
exactly 35% had cystic fibrosis and 100%
had muscular distopy publish it in
English publish it in the Journal of
Trace element research very well
respected scientific journal of the
United States the equivalent journals in
Chinese in China sent copies to the MUSC
Foundation to the Cystic Fibrosis
Foundation never heard a word from them
somebody needs to go to jail you all
heard of shal paly shal paly is one of
these gradient diseases it's a gradient
disease disease different degrees of
severity baby's born with 10% of his
cerebellum which is the part of the
brain that's damaged when you have
cereal paly 10% damage 10%
underdevelopment the baby's going to
kind of walk like Charlie Chaplain and
with braces and some physical therapy
they can kind of circumvent that
disability they have a 25%
underdevelopment of their cerebellum
they kind of flop around a little bit
and with their arms and hands and upper
body as well as their legs and you know
they have cerebral paly they have 50%
development they're going to be
restricted to a wheelchair this girl
here has has 90% underdevelopment of her
cerebel in the size of a grape instead
of a tangerine and you can see her she
has clamps on her head holding it up uh
since she was born and she's 11 years
old here since she was born people have
to wipe her bottom here she is um it's
now two years later after this picture
has taken she's now 13 she's 11 in this
picture she's going through puberty
somebody's going to have to change her
tampons wipe her bottom feed her do
everything do everything for her give
her massages three or four times a day
to prevent pressure ulcers all this
Machinery is needed to move her around
care extraordinary care it's $5 million
a year for that child there's 10,000
babies born with this disease in America
every year whose fault is that OBGYN
totally preventable this is the part of
the brain is underdeveloped when you
have the cerebellum when you have
cerebral Psy same way with belly button
hernas it's a gradient disease here's a
pretty typical belly button hernie the
size of a walnut just you give that baby
hypnotic either by injection or gas puts
local anesthesia around that 10 minutes
the procedure is done you've you've
repaired that belly button hernia but
the baby shouldn't have to go through
that M was missing something during
pregnancy for that to happen this next
one the baby was born dead a vascular
shock because the defect went from the 2
in below the belly button through the
belly button to two inches above it and
there's no skin over it and the stomach
and the spleen and some of the
intestines are hanging out and you can
see were why didn't the the obgy and
know that that baby was suffering from
vascular shock while he was in the
bathroom giving himself drugs this one
here the defect goes from the pubic bone
all the way to the middle of the chest
and he the liver and the stomach the
spleen and all the intestines are
hanging out you can see how that baby
would die from vascular shock being born
that way where where was the OBGYN that
baby's perfect brain is perfect lungs
are perfect heart's perfect liver is
perfect everything's perfect it died
from vast shop because all its insides
are hanging out during birth that baby
was delivered by cerian section would be
alive today somebody needs to go to jail
here same with CLE pent it's a gradiant
disease different degrees of severity
whether you're rich or poor if the
mother's deficient in zinc in the first
3 to seven weeks of pregnancy you can
get clef pallet and many other defects
kids are born deaf congenital deafness
doctors want you believe is genetic and
there they're raising money they have
all these funds to raise money to
prevent you know change the genes fix
the genes it's caused by deficiency of a
single mineral called manganese not
magnesium manganese deficiency in the
first 3 to seven weeks of pregnancy
causes congenital deafness this new book
that pharmacist Ben talked about when he
introduced me is called epigenetics
epigenetics tells you that the genetic
theory of disease transmission is one of
those dead theories there is not a
single disease that's transmitted
genetically the death of the genetic
theory of disease transmission the death
of the genetic theory of disease
transmission there's thousands of dead
theories of the medical trade in the
halls of Science and the epigenetics
tells you that these diseases that are
said to be genetic are preventable many
of them reversible with nutritional
supplementation prior to conception a
lot of diseases that like Huntington
disease which is a disease that kind of
Falls in between Parkin disease and Ms
lugaric disease they said to be genetic
it occurs in people 50 years of age and
older come on okay we'll get into that
in a little bit totally preventable
reversible the death of the genetic
theory of disease transmission that's me
in 1977 with one of my cystic fibrosis
monkeys you've all heard of obesity
versus the medical Theory and the
government's theory of why America is
obese and overweight is because we don't
exercise enough we eat too much well
following their Theory to eat less and
exercise more we became the number one
obese nation in the world we're number
one the only thing we can brag about
being number one in the health area is
we're obese by following their Theory so
obviously that theory didn't work so
what causes obesity what causes people
to over be overweight if it's not lack
of exercise and eating too much well
it's a simple nutritional deficiency you
take the nutrients and it goes away
we'll get into that in some detail if we
have time multiple sclerosis a disease
that historically occurred primarily in
people between the ages of 30 and and 60
Ms today in the last 10 years the peak
of the demographic curve of of who gets
Ms are kids under the age of 12 they're
even diagnosing Ms now and 10-month old
babies 10-month old babies how's that
happening free radical damage to the
mile in the brain free radical damage in
the mile of the brain well why is it now
we're getting it in young babies 10
months old and it used to and people 50
years old that's because our babies are
getting free radicals damaging their M
of the brain or were they getting the
free radicals apple juice what happens
when you cut an apple in half and leave
it exposed to the air without putting
lemon juice on it it turns brown what's
turning brown in the Apple it's
oxidation of the oil in the apple apple
juice is not taken care of very well
it's one of the first non formula things
you give a baby is you know an ounce of
apple juice and 8 ounces of water in a
little bottle they're they're giggling
they're happy but the free radicals that
build up because of the apple juice
oxidizing the oil and the apple juice
oxidizing causes MS and little babies
thrombotic stroke again used to be in
people over the ages of 50 60 70 now the
peak of the demographic curve are kids
under the age of 18 how's that happening
well thrombotic stroke doesn't occur
because of genetics thrombotic stroke
doesn't occur just out of dumb luck it's
caused by an omega-3 essential fatty
acid deficiency a ratio problem between
Omega-3s sixes and nines that's another
one of my lawsuits against the FDA
because I prevailed in federal court I
can legally say that you can actually
prevent thrombotic stroke you can
prevent pulmonary emis you can prevent
Carn thrombosis and deep vein thrombosis
simply by supplementing with omega-3
essential fatty acids and having a
perfect ratio between omega3 sixes and
NES before I sue them and one in federal
court I couldn't say that without
getting put in jail how many of you give
your kids and grandkids under the age of
five 1,000 milligrams of supplemental
Omega-3s every
day gosh I don't see any hands going up
that's why your kids are going to die
before you from Ms and stroke and stuff
like that heart attacks Kean disease
cardiomyopathy heart disease so how come
this is happening now why are they
getting all these Strokes we didn't get
had strokes and were in her 50s 6070s
that's because we were getting Omega-3s
when we were kids well wait a minute we
didn't supplement well yeah you did it
was in egg yolks our kids now are living
in Fruity Pebbles and apple juice Sunny
Delight and Shredded Wheat wel as grape
juice and Cheerios how many mega 3es are
in them nothing nothing z0 you better be
supplementing your kids and your
grandkids before they're conceived all
through the pregnancy develop them from
the moment they're born with all 90
essential nutrients and you'll avoid all
this stuff now the most politically
charged of all of the congenital events
birth effects if you will is another one
of these gradient disease like belly
button hernas cerebral paly it's totally
100% preventable but once the baby's
born it's irreversible homosexuality in
both males and female occurred in the
first 3 to seven weeks of pregnancy
there's a part of the brain called the
preoptic hypothalamus that controls not
your gender but controls who you go
after for sex your gender is determined
genetically but there's a piece of your
brain that determines who you will go
after for sex a boy or a girl and it
could be different from your genetic sex
and that's what happens with
homosexuality asexuality U
hermaphrodites all that kind of stuff
because what goes on up here is
different from your genetic sex now
interx babies ones that are they're
hermaphrodites they have both male and
female parts the medical system in
America they will look for bar bodies
which is the second female hormone the
second excuse me chromosome second
female chromosome called a bar body and
you can see that every nucleus of the
white blood cell in a blood sample from
a newborn baby that has a hermaphrodite
has both the male female parts when they
have the bar bodies um they're female
genetically and here's some real this is
a line drawing obviously but here here's
bar bodies in some real XX female blood
smears and you can see in a male XY
there's nuclei because it's getting
ready to divide but there's no bar
bodies bar bodies are totally different
than the nuclei and so when they find a
baby that is her Aphrodite but they have
bar bodies they will surgically move the
penis and the testicles do a little
plastic surgery and beat their chest and
say I did good I did good for this baby
well 85% of the time when the baby's
born her atite up here in their preoptic
hypothalamus they're male 85% of the
time they're male and our pediatric
surgeons and obgy have done some of the
most cruel things to these babies born
hermaphrodites while in Europe in
Scandinavia they wait till the babies
are 10 years old because by the time
they're 10 years old the babies know
which one they are in their preoptic
hypothalamus they have both parts and
you ask the baby they're 10 years old
well are you you know you got both parts
there Frank I mean it's obvious you know
that but really which one are you are
you a girl or boy said well I'm a boy
and so they cut off the vagina and the
ovaries and do some plastic surgery and
then make him a boy even though
genetically it might be a female it's
the kindest thing to do do it that way
one more and then I'll show you the part
of the brain that's Afflicted and then
we'll get to the bottom line here this
fell here very famous eye surgeon in
central California his name is Richard
and Richard fathered several cute kids
very famous for dealing with laser
surgery to tack down detach retinas uh
he was very active in his church he was
very active in in things like the Rotary
Club Rotary International and liance
Club raising money for projects but when
his last child reached 18 years of age
he went from Central California to
Denver Colorado had his penis and
testical amputated had a vagina made had
breast implants got hormone treatments
and went from Richard to Renee because
since he was 10 years old he knew up
here that he was a she now this is a
part of the brain that's Afflicted this
is not a part of the brain that's
necessary for life I mean you you cut
the braid off here you're going to die
you cut this part of the brain off
you're going to be a vegetable and just
lay there like a worm you cut this part
of the brain off you're going to be dead
but this little peninsula here the the
preoptic hypothalamus about the size of
my little finger if there's no cells in
there there's about 400 cells in there
normally if there's no cells in there
the individual is asexual everybody has
a Crazy Aunt Ruthie or crazy Uncle Frank
who the legend goes they went on a date
when they were 20 and their boyfriend or
girlfriend jilted them I don't know how
you can jilt somebody after one date but
they said they jilted them and they
never went out again cuz they were so
wounded from being jilted after that one
date and they died never having get
gotten married well they were asexual
just really weren't interested in sex
but everybody else was going on dates so
they thought they'd try it once and so
on if there's a few more cells in there
say 25 to 50 they're bisexual they love
having orgasms but they don't care if
it's a male or female get a few more
cells in there it depends on what part
of that preoptic hypothalamus is
involved let's say you got 150 cells in
there now but they're in one place which
drives you to chase boys but genetically
you're a male you're being pulled by
your preoptic hypothalamus to chase boys
okay you're a male homosexual if you're
female and it tells you to chase females
you're a lesbian you have 250 cells to
400 cells you're heterosexual that's how
it works totally preventable however
after the baby's born can't go back you
can't put the genie back in the bottle
here's the bottom line folks all
vertebrates whether you're a hummingbird
or a human being or an elephant require
90 essential nutrients how long do you
need oxygen for Life how long do you
need water for Life how long do you need
the 90 essential nutrients for life
there's 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential Meo acids three essential
fatty acids and they're called essential
for two reasons number one we can't make
them we must consume them every day
either as food or supplements and if
they're missing secondly if they're
missing for any length of time you get
horrible diseases all of which are fatal
plants only need three minerals to make
good seeds for the Next Generation we
need 60s so if you're eating a pretty
good slice of organically grown
multigrain bread baked With Love by the
pastor's wife in the church on Sunday
when he gives his very best sermon he's
ever given his whole life your 57
mineral Shar this article is from food
chemistry and food chemistry is a very
well respected scientific journal it's
very boring it just tells you where they
grow food and how many nutrients is in
that food from that County or that plat
of land how many plants or what the
plant load is this particular issue
April 16th 2012 they did an article
where they analyze the nutritional value
in the plant load in baby formulas eight
classic baby formulas in America and
Canada that everybody knows and respects
Gerbers infil himac ones like that and
they said commercially available baby
foods may contain less than 20% of the
recommended levels of minerals and
vitamins dog food has 100% laboratory
rat food has 100% chicken food has 100%
And your babies grandbabies and babies
have less than 20% somebody needs to go
to jail that's why you must supplement
you cannot depend on quote eating well
you cannot depend on eating well 60
years ago we had perfected perfect dog
food we spent a hundred billion dollar
perfecting dog food what did we get for
that well we tripled their lifespan over
60 years 6 years ago an old dog was 8
years old dogs 25 we eliminated 900
different diseases that still plague
humans including all birth effects you
can name and 10 times that many you can
we didn't do that with Argan transplants
we didn't do that with genetically
engineered protein stem cells or wonder
drugs we did it simply by putting
vitamins and minerals in their dog food
this is um the weekend Magazine from the
Globe and Mail up in Canada glob and
mail is their equivalent of the USA
Today this article was written by a
medical doctor and he was wanting you to
eat real food and not take vitamin
mineral tablets and pills and capsules I
do both for breakfast I'll have have
four poached eggs and a steak I'll have
a baked sweet potato with butter and
cinnamon I'll have all my supplements
for lunch I have a couple of snacks I
have another light load of my
supplements at dinner time I'll have
some grilled salmon with a great salad
I'll have some dessert and I will have
my supplements I eat very well I have
steak at least once a day at least once
a day better yet three times a day right
I avoid oil I avoid burning my Foods I
won't eat if it's burnt I avoid gluten
no wheat BR R and oats I take all my
supplements you see if you eat well how
many milligrams of calcium are you going
to get from that Apple you can't tell
how many micrograms of sing are you
going to get from one inch wedge of that
Apple you can't tell how many
international use of vitamin A or beta
kene are you get from eating a slice of
that tomato you can't tell so I'm going
to eat well but I'm going to also take
my supplements because I know how many
milligrams how many units how many
micrograms of everything I'm getting
because I'm not going to leave my life
from the life of my kids and grandkids
and great-grandkids and great great
grandkid up to chance to the throw of
the dice what may or may not be in that
food I want to make sure everything is
there perfect the equivalent of not
supplementing would be to put a couple
of shovels full of dirt from Texas in
the crank case of your car say wellow
there's probably oil in there cuz that
dirts from Texas that'd be really stupid
wouldn't it when you just eat well and
you don't supplement with everything you
know properly to to make sure you get
everything you need worse yet if you
don't supplement your kids and grandkids
and great-grandkids rich people
thousands of years ago royalties wealthy
noblemen wealthy merchants would get
their minerals from mummy dust you go to
the Grave robber who already sold off
all the jewelry and the clothes and
trinkets that were buried with him but
he kept the mummy cuz there was more
money in the mummy than there was in the
trinkets you go to the everybody knew
where the grave robbers were just like
back in the probation days everybody
could get whiskey even though it was IL
illegal right and so you go to the Grave
robber and say look I got arthritis my
right hip and he go cut the right hip
off the mummy grind it up give you the
powder in 6 weeks time your hip was
cured it would go away the arthri go
away why because human joints have
Condren sulfate glucosamine sulfate
hyaluronic acid collagen vitamin A
vitamin D calcium magnesium has all this
stuff and it would repair that joint now
human joints are a lot more expensive
than chicken joints right and so slaves
and subsistence Farmers couldn't get
their minerals in the same fashion so
where did they get their minerals from
wood ashes wood ashes are not really
ashes they the plant minerals that are
left when you burn away the wood powder
that's left in the fireplace the wood
stove is really plant minerals you throw
in the garden and the corn and the peas
and the sweet potatoes and the onions
and the tomatoes and and peppers
whatever you're growing out there suck
up these minerals you throw them in the
garden the plants them up eat the plants
you get your minerals in that fashion
well that was the way we supplemented
with our minerals that's the way the the
traditional way we got minerals for
thousands and thousands and thousands
and thousands and thousands of years
until 3:00 in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 on Pearl Street in
New York City on the bluff overlooking
the construction of the Brooklyn Bridge
with this fell here Thomas Edison pulled
the switch on the first commercial
electric generating plant within 10
years every town and every municipality
and every city in the industrialized
World converted from wood as the
universal fuel to electricity how many
wood ashes how many plant metals are
left over when you fuel your home with
electricity instead of wood zero and
what did you replace your traditional
source of nutritional minerals with
nothing and here comes a well-respected
individual a doctor saying now don't you
supplement with vitamins minerals you
can overdose you know you better be
saving your money for pharmaceuticals
you're going to need it as you get older
this is a satellite picture from 100
miles up Southern California
agricultural land this is Mexico down
here um Arizona over here Pacific Ocean
over here this is the salt and sea so
you know exactly where this is at in
Southern California the salt see is a
Salt Lake about 1/10th the size of the
Great Salt Lake in Utah but what don't
you see here is the nutritional minerals
do not occur in a uniform blanket around
the crust of the earth nutritional
minerals occur in veins like chocolate
and chable ice cream these different
colors and Swirls and whirls are telling
you these whirls and swirls are made up
of different minerals different mixtures
of minerals different amounts of each
one and the only way we can guarantee
that every mouthful and every animal
that eats soybeans they're grown here
corn that's grown here whatever might be
grown here they're going to put in their
feed we're going to give them we're
going to supplement them with everything
we know they need for maximum life no
birth effects going to maximum
production of milk meat eggs when you
look at that label on the dog food on
the chicken food on the dairy food on
beef cattle feed that label reflects
only what we put in there not what the
food got out of the soil what the food
got out of the soil is value added but
it's a throw of the dice so we put
everything we know they need for perfect
everything we put it in there this is a
compost pile that contains 77 minerals
in it these are plant derived minerals
this is a compost well this is plants
there's 100 cubic miles of this stuff
there's a 10,000 years Supply if
everybody in the earth uses the stuff
these guys are standing on a road 3,000
ft elevation above sea level this white
cap is 25t thick Marine Limestone we
know it's Marine Limestone because the
animal and plant fossils in the
Limestone are from the ocean this has
zero pollution it was under the sea for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years the ultimate question is do you
put oil in your car before the engine
burns up or after the engine burns up
you put oil in your car before the
engine burns up you change your oil over
3,000 Mi whatever the maintenance book
says you'll get 300,000 Mi out of that
engine if you put water in in that car
instead of oil that car might not go 50
mil so you know to put the oil in the
car well methusa lived be 969 those in
the Old Testament who begat so and so
who begat so and so who begat so and so
they live to be 150 200 300 so who knows
how long we can live we do everything
right so isn't it sane to supplement
with everything we know we need in
perfect amounts eat right but make sure
we're getting everything perfectly like
we do putting oil and cars before the
end burns up now myself next month using
the Chinese method of Aging I'll be 75
using the American aging system I'll be
74 I have not been to a doctor with me
being the patient for the last 68 years
I've never been on prescription
medication I have no health problems
whatsoever and nobody's going to steal
an airplane with me on it now if
everybody were like me medically the
medical system would be real humble if
their patients only came to them once
every 75 years wouldn't they they'd be
real humble I've been taking the 90
essential nutrients twice a day since I
was 9 years old been taking this program
twice a day since I was nine now I'm not
stupid enough to think that I a
nine-year-old kid figured this out by
myself I figur I had some Divine
guidance there right and so I feel that
I'm obligated to keep sharing this with
people if I had Divine guidance got rid
of one of my health problems when I was
nine that was it never had a health
problem again it's all preventable
there's only two reasons why you won't
get the result you're looking for only
two reasons maybe three number one
you're underdosing a 200 lb person
taking enough for a 50 lb kid ain't
going to work as they say in France and
then you can't absorb it you're dosing
perfectly but you're only getting 10%
because you can't absorb it you are not
what you eat you are what you absorb
thirdly you're underdosing and you can't
absorb so 10% of nothing's not very much
the most common reason why people are
not absorbing is gluten intolerance
people say I'm gluten-free I mean I'm
obsessive about it I am gluten-free you
have a dog yep you have dry dog food yep
you're not gluten-free because dyed dog
food is made from gluten you have a cat
yep give them Drive cat food yep well
you're not gluten-free well I can't get
my spouse to give up gluten well you're
not gluten-free then everybody the
household including the Mother-in-law
the spouse the dog the cat the bird the
fish because of cross-contamination the
laundry the couch where everybody
watches TV the food preparation surface
the bed you sleep in everything
everybody in the household's got to be
gluten-free otherwise you're not
gluten-free and then of course you need
stomach acid you cannot be drinking
alkaline water during meals because you
neutralize your stomach acid to absorb
minerals to digest proteins to absorb
B12 your stomach pH got to be pH 1.2
it's got to be like battery acid it also
keeps your stomach stal so you don't
have yeast and bacteria growing there
you won't have reflux makes reflux go
away so when people tell me they haven't
gotten the results have to go back and
do a little investigation do a little
housekeeping figure out why you're not
absorbing are you underdosing or you
have to look at all those things because
this program I've been doing for 36
years will never fail if it fails it
means you're not absorbing or you're
underdosing or both and thank you very
much for being a good
[Applause]
audience
[Music]